sujet délicat si nous allons à présent
parler du 7e festival du vent qui vient
de s'achever a quant lui quand et cette
année il célébrait le 50e anniversaire
de la déclaration des droits de l'homme
à l'anniversaire qui a amené de
nombreuses rencontres entre inventeurs
artistes écologistes et autres amoureux
et adepte du vent les enfants n'ont pas
été oubliés avec notamment un atelier
cerf volant philippe rey
un souffle d'air patte sur calvi commun
vont charger d'humanité ils sont
scientifiques sportifs plasticiens
artistes ou inventeur tout en tout 500
invités bénévoles venus échanger des
idées des émotions à l'acte et droits de
l'homme pour ligne d'horizon
est bien dans la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et qu'il est interdit de
faire travailler des enfants eh bien
vous racontera des enfants de votre âge
qui travaillent dans des pays bas pour
cela on voit sa volée intervenons pour
dire qu'on pense un petit poêle et ça
marche vous savez compter aussi les
enfants des bruits
certes l'apprentissage est un peu
difficile mais bon l'important c'est
avant tout dit croire
on participe aussi à l'atelier
confection et là encore les tout petits
sont rois
un proche du peintre
cette consultation ne s'est pas du tout
su et enfin faire pour faire un phare
paulhan on le sait voler ils n'avaient
en
été c'est un jour donné
les plus grands eux prête une oreille
attentive
tout ça
et voilà tu as ta forme de cerfs-volants
à partir de là maintenant on va
fabriquer
la membrure avec des baguettes on est
content après on a fait cette soirée
pierre frantz à luzech c'est ça qui est
intéressant est le con dios
alors on se fait disciples des sommes à
l'affût de ses moindres caprices et la
part de rêve
pourquoi pas atteindre de grandes idées
avec le cerf-volant on peut aussi
exprimé des thèmes forment comme la soul
est comme la solidarité par exemple il
suffit de mettre une chaîne de
cerfs-volants dans le ciel pour
démontrer aux enfants que en associant
des cerfs-volants et bien on est plus
fort et on va plus haut et plus loin